let's get right into the tax tip folks
tax season's around the corner
a very story came out yesterday about
taxes get your paper and pen ready this
may uh uh uh
help somebody you know uh because irs is
actually serious about this irs says
to report stolen property as income
unless you could return it the same year
this is a fox 4 news kansas city story
it's also usa today story an image
circulating on social media purpose that
to show an iris guideline asking
taxpayers to report any value of any
property they've stolen each year as
income the guideline is real the irs
publication 17 available on agency's
website contains a section on stolen
property that may leave readers
scratching if you can pull up the
picture so people can't see it here's
what it looks like
illegal activities income from illegal
activities such as money from dealing
drugs illegal drugs must be included in
your income as schedule one stolen
property if you steal property you must
report it
in your income in the near in the year
you stole it unless it unless in the
same year you choose to return it to its
rightful owner so that's your tax tip of
the day tom what are your thoughts on
this well what i think is going to
happen is you're going to have some dumb
criminals and there are those
and they're going to turn in their taxes
they're going to say thank you very much
for paying your taxes we've forwarded
this to the fbi have a nice day
i mean these guys talk i mean this is
it's it's either a joke or a hook
but i i can't believe the literal the
literalness
that it's in the code yeah so so uh uh
the uh years ago they said capone got
caught like this
this is how they caught capone they came
out with a law like this
and then they fell forward and yeah so
tax evasion is what it is but this is
slightly different than tax evasion you
steal a car report it i made seventeen
thousand dollars because i stored 17
what's the uh depreciation on this i got
vehicle i got so this is not an onion
headline this is actual real stuff
because it seems like an onion headline
if there's ever been one
those of you that joined in a riot and
got yourself three or four of those
70-inch tvs took them home remember
those seem like tax-paying citizens
right exactly remember remember that's
three grand each that's nine grand needs
to be on line 16 of your tax form yeah
no it's okay i had i
said i i have a c corp that i do all of
my theft under so we're just you know a
subsidiary
first time i saw this i thought it was a
joke yeah i'm not even kidding with you
by the way i posted a yesterday on
instagram tulsi gabbard responded yeah
and she said i had to did you see what
she said no she said i went online to
verify this it's unbelievable that it's
real that's what tulsi said this is the
national uh or the government website
there you go that's the website
put the link in comment section so
people want to go to they can go honest
to god though i mean all jokes aside
this tells you everything you need to
know about progressive america right now
because they don't care about you me or
this fellow citizen steal from you just
make sure you give us a little bit but
you know what i love patrick you know
it's all right burn down a business just
don't come anywhere near the capitol ah
you know
mostly people over there just don't do
it here that's who these people are it's
a let them eat cake
the regulations are an exercise in
comedy look at what's right below the
stolen property transporting school
children don't include in your income a
school board mileage allowance for
taking children to and from school so in
other words you cannot deduct mileage
for taking kids back and forth to school
but you must declare that property
imagine like what
what world are we even living in anymore
i mean even even the mayor of san
francisco a far left progressive mayor
she's like oh lyndon
london london it's like
these policies i don't even know like we
got 13 billion dollars and we've got
everybody on the same page everybody's
in the same party and uh we've got
nothing but crime theft human [ __ ] and
and people sleeping in the streets maybe
i don't know maybe we need those and
shooting smack yeah
by the way you said you know there's
going to be some drug dealers out there
that have stolen stuff that they're
going to put this on their taxes zero
people are doing this zero zero nobody's
like smoking weed sitting there with
their stolen goods
all their drug money around them like
sorry baby i'm doing my c-corp taxes
right now like not happening
people are doing this steals a car and
then pays their taxes
who's taking inventory on what they
stole in a riot who's taking inventory
like well that's one of the three guys
there's no receipts
underestimating the amount of uh dummies
we have in america you are really giving
people way too much credit there's a lot
of people
that will you ever seen the the what is
the video that says the dummy criminal
of the week or the dummy yeah there is
plenty of strange
stupid criminals that think they can get
away the file voluntary by the way i
don't even think these criminals are
filing taxes they're much less
voluntarily admitting theft i'm just
telling you don't underestimate you guys
okay only
which i'm not or if i were a drug dealer
which i'm not and i wouldn't want to
give this corrupt government any money
what i would do instead of and again
this is just
is i would take those assets and i may
or may not invest in some ethereum and
then use that ethereum to create an nft
and then take that nft and sell it to
myself at a loss so then i don't know we
got him pat we got him we got him
defense let's go call him up by the way
adam call him up open the door they're
coming all right so let's go to the next
store and they're not going to be high
while they're you know filling out their
tax returns what we've already
determined is they're high coding from
microsoft so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]